hey david what do you think the legacy
of donald trump will be
these questions are tough because it
really you need
time to pass to be able to say but
if the george w bush presidency is any
indication
sometimes you can tell pretty quickly
what do i mean by that
when george w bush left office my belief
was his legacy would be
um squandering the goodwill that came
after 911 by invading the wrong country
iraq in response to the 9 11 attacks
and then dramatically escalating
domestic surveillance
and privacy uh incursions with the
patriot act etc that's what if you said
on
obama's day one what is george w bush's
legacy going to be
i would have said that it was that and
that is essentially what george w bush's
legacy has been
so sometimes you can tell right away if
you ask me today what will trump's
legacy
be i think it will be
trump as the ultimate buffoon who
mishandled
kovid and ruined relationships around
the world even the ruined relationships
around the world may fade
as joe biden restores those
relationships but really
the covet failure inciting a riot
being impeached twice and being sort of
a buffoon
strike me as what are most likely to be
donald trump's uh
legacies when when people talk about
a president the first thing you often go
to is what were the big
failures with george w bush it was you
invaded the wrong country after 9 11.
that stixx that's legislation aside
tax cuts okay yeah bush did a little bit
of tax cutting and then taxes went up a
little under obama and down a little bit
under donald trump
i don't think that's going to be the
stuff of legacies trump would like the
wall to be his legacy
he just didn't build it claiming to have
built it doesn't make you doesn't make
it a legacy if you didn't actually do it
unless you can trick a lot of people
when you think about what is trump's big
failure
my mind goes to his complete and total
failure
of handling and of leadership around
coronavirus
the capital attack because it's not even
a failure it's actually a misdeed
he incited the riots at the capitol
that will be there and then i do think
from a demeanor standpoint
being this buffoon so easily triggered
the thinnest skinned president we've
maybe ever had
who you know was enamored with
authoritarians and ruined relationships
with our historical allies
and then in pop culture it seems that he
will be sort of seen as a nixon type for
a little while except trump impeached
twice rather than nixon who resigned
he'll be sort of the butt of jokes
and the the the go to the meme of the
delusional dumb
corrupt president but over time we will
see
those are my instincts and he will be
seen as a one-term president who
accomplished
nothing in terms of solid legislation
and who who did some really horrible
things
now what you know what about barack
obama what is it
what is barack obama's legacy i'm
curious to hear from you
for me obama's legacy is obamacare
president during the legalization of gay
marriage
and unfortunately scaling up drone
warfare
that's what i think about when i think
about barack obama
um and unfortunately when you do three
bullet points you miss a lot
i mean you what the intangible value
of barack obama making the u.s
more respected around the world than it
had been in a long time
compared to donald trump making the u.s
tragically not respected around the
world that's more of an intangible
that's hard to put on a list but i do
think that under barack obama that that
certainly was
uh one of the important things but does
that show up on a bullet pointed list
no it's obamacare at the top drone
warfare
tell me what else what else would be
under obama's legacy those are my
thoughts right now
let me know your answer to the primary
question which is
what will the legacy be of donald trump
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com if you want you can
use the coupon code better21
to save a huge amount i won't even tell
you how much
better21 is the coupon code we'll see
you on the bonus show